Well, to my trouble, I was never
particularly interested in money, so in
hindsight I was smarter, but I
played tennis because of money, that
was never a motivating reason when you
became a winner, but
I wanted to win eyelashes, just
become mine and then whether I could do something  Earning
or not was always secondary now
she can say yes, easy to say, at 17
I already had my first million but
I partially forgot the prize money so I
forgot the check while training when
the animals came just then or in
my mother we still have to okay,
you do that  The times I wanted to win were
bad times and that was my
motivation, that was also my
elixir of life